Mindy Kaling is officially a mom I'm so
excited it's amazing
according to E news the Mindy project
star has given birth to her first child
a girl named Catherine K Lane the
actress has yet to reveal the child's
father's identity feel so grateful and
excited Kailyn first opened up about her
pregnancy in August here's what she told
The Today Show about embracing
motherhood it's so unknown to me I'm
kind of um I have a lot of control over
a lot of aspects of my life and this is
one where I'm like okay well just it's
out of my hands which is a kind of a fun
feeling the timing feels serendipitous
for Kaling who ended her journey on the
Mindy project just a month before giving
birth here's what she told Ellen
DeGeneres in October my mother who was
an OBGYN who I play an OBGYN on the show
if she passed away it was within the
same hour that I thought I found out
that the show had been greenlit
now the show is ending when I found out
that I was pregnant with my own daughter
and it was it felt like the show kind of
helped me and trained me to kind of grow
up and become a mom
[Music]